adam i got a quick mayweather story me
and me in batch king batch we went to um
vegas because that's where he was living
at to shoot a vine it's back when vine
was huge
so we get to his house and we we i mean
we were downstairs for like an hour
remember what were there 15 seconds like
six seconds six six so we're at his
house and he we waited downstairs for
about an hour we never met him yet or
whatever so we finally hook up with him
so he's like i gotta go to the bank so
we go to the bank and it's me floyd and
bass we're walking over there and it's
these two big security guards this is
random character way down the block and
we're like yo there's some guy watching
us he's like oh no no i don't worry
about him that's the shooter i was like
what
so he has like a random
guy who stands a hundred feet away with
just like a pistol and just watches
to make sure that nothing happens there
with people around though it makes sense
i think you do man [ __ ] i mean it
happened so fast yeah it happened so
fast you know when you're on that level
for sure you gotta you know you gotta
secure what you gotta say you never
reach